Today's One Minute Monday is: "Scare yourself."
This morning I reached out to an old buddy of mine named George,
who used to help out a lot in the Salsa classes I had him.
And he hasn't helped for 3 years because he hurt his shoulder and I said:
"George, I'm putting on a class. I really want you to come out and help out,
I think it'd be a lot of fun.
I miss you, it'd be great to see you again."
And he said: "Thanks so much for reaching out. You know what? I'd love to,
but I'm really scared. I haven't danced in 3 years."
I said: "George, you've got to do something to scare yourself each day, right?"
And he said: "You know what? Thanks for the kick in the pants, I'll come out."
So, for today, I want you to scare yourself.
Do one thing, just today that you have this limiting self-belief about,
that you're holding yourself back on.
Do one thing today that scares you a little bit. Maybe it's reaching out to somebody who you never...
thought would return your phone call. Maybe it's emailing somebody.
Maybe it's saying "yes" to a meeting.
Something! Think of something that you really want, that in your ideal world exists...
but you're too afraid to go out and ask for.
And just for today, step outside your comfort zone and go for it!
It'll make you a stronger and better person. And you never know what will happen.
Believe!
If you guys liked this video, thumbs up below.
Leave a comment, let me know what you think.
Let me know what you're going to do today that scares you.
And click on my face, subscribe to the channel.
Thank you, guys. I'll see you soon.
Subtitles by the Amara.org community